Mark: Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Rock of Ages and welcome back Shodleech.
M: How're you doing?
Shod: I'm doing good, and today I guess we're going to be having another match of Rock of Ages,
S: and this time, I'm still gonna kick your butt.
M: Yeah, yeah, we don't know anything about that because that video doesn't exist except over on your channel.
M: So if you guys want to see what happened my- my recording failed, but in reality
M: I just didn't want my poor performance to be shown on camera on my perspective.
M: So we're gonna be having another little go at this.
M: I'm waiting. We're all waiting.
S: I know I'm so sorry! M: We're all waiting.
M: Uh-Huh? Mm-Hmm? Okay.
M: It all comes down to this, it all comes down to one epic match of unbelievable proportions.
M: To be able to kick you in the tush, and then you're gonna-  you're gonna feel the rock up against your vlad.
S: Well, today we're going into Witches' Sabbath.
M: Okay. I don't know. What is a- oh nice trollface rock. What is a Sabbath?
M: Oh boy. I don't know where I'm supposed to be able to build stuff, but here we go. I guess.
M: Aw gee whiz, Scoob.
M: OH GEE WIZZ SKOOB!!!
S: Well crap. I'm having the issue this time.
S: My game remote's not working!
*insert gigglyplier*
M: You have a little bit of trouble over there you having some 'prablems'?
S: Oh, well, yeah
S: Just a little bit, I'll be okay
M: Oh yeah okay alright. Ooh not cooperating much are you ooh no.
S: I gotta put stuff in one direction.
M: One Direction? S: Not supposed to be a reference. M: Uh-huh.
M: Uh where- where do the- where do the boulders...
M: Ahh, Oh, Oo-kay.
M: Heh all right. I think I know how to deal with someone like you. You...
M: ...deserve what you're about to get in your face. So why don't you just eat a looooot of this.
*hehe sex joke
S: Well, so I guess this time. I'm the one using cable.
(wat?)
M: Uh-huh. yeah. Oh- oh (laughing)
M: You havin' some trouble there oh-ho. S: Please
S: They're gonna- M: You havin'- you having some trouble there? S: They're mammoths!
M: Oh, I think- I think maybe it's my turn to get out there all hope you guys.
M: hope you don't have too much waiting for me S: The mammoths!
S: I think the mammoths almost destroyed my boulder.
M: I know I know my mammoths are pretty incre- well
M: I don't know this map. Oh
M: Shoot, Shootie, shoot. I'm a doof. Okay hang on.
M: Is the keyboard giving you some trouble there? S: It is, but I've not...
...barely- yet the mammoths were kind of an issue there.
M: Uh-oh, Uh-oh, Uh-oh.
M: Eughehehe. Oh, Nellie, oh.
M: Are those mammoths or are those just uh- 'elefantes'?
S: Ah! Crud you blew up my boulder M: Krillin? Wait. I blew up your boulder?
S: Yes M: Like blew up for good?
M: *gasp*
M: Ooh I've never done that before- don't hey, hey come on. You think your cows can beat me, huh? If ya-
M: Uh-oh
M: Ah. Oh Crap.
M: Oh boy
M: IIIII am in trouble
M: Bonk
M: ooh boy. Oh, I see you. I see you on the way. No you think you can- it's too late buddy-boo
M: It's toooooo...
M: Laaaaaaaate!
M: Bonk.
M: Ooh, ah, ooh, how's it- ooh- feel?
M: Mmm, Feel good? It feels pretty-. S: I Love it. M: I bet you do, I bet you do. Now I ...
Have more
M: Surpurses (aka surprises) for ya, and I think again like I said in the previous, you're gonna probably like this one. A like a lot
M: Cuz, uhh, I don't know if you've ever heard of the- S: NO NO NO! NO WERMEHEFFAS!
M: When did you get ahead of it? S: I just got past it!
M: WHEN IN THE HECK!?!? That's not fair!
M: Hang on.
Hang on X2
Hang on X3
Hang on X4
MAXIMUM HANGDRIVE X5!!!
S: mArK?
M: Yeah- Yeah what about it?
M: What about- What about it? What about it? What- What about it? What about? What's the deal? What's the deal? What's up, man? What's up?
S:The deal is I ain't gonna lose to you so easily.
M: Uh-huh sure yeah, okay. That's what they all..
SAY!!!
Direct hit! Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho! Okay.
*ANGERY SHOD!*
M: Yeah, yeah, yeah yeah yeah, yeah, oh.
S: The trophy shall not be defeated. (?)
M: Oh yeah. Oh yeah, it's too late for you,
You know you might as well just you know give up.
S: Yeah, I kinda fell again.
M: Did you fall again? Good!
S: I fell again.
M: GOOD, GoOd, Good, good.
Excellent!
As you should.
S: *muah-ha-ha evil laugh!* M:Let me ask you a question. How does uh- how does defeat taste? Does- Is it good, is it bitter?
S: It's a little salty
M: Like a like a summer shanty you know *rolls tounge* there's a little bit little bit tepid on the tongue.
S: It's straight up salt... and that cannon... smacked right in the face by a cannon
*The evil laugh of a wild Markimoo*
M: Oh... I think - I think your time is
Is-is-is-is come!
S: If that cannon has anything to say about it, I think you're right. M: Heeee
eeebooskey, oh this was a mistake
Oh boy, I made a bit of an error there, but, it's alright I think that someone
lied to me oh
Made it, made it nailed it. Ooh boy. I am making it somewhere. Whoo what the heck? How?
Uh-oh, this is going to be quite a fall
It's gonna be a bit thunderous oof that did some dooblage, but you know what's going to do more damlage?
You know what you know it's going to do more damage this! Boink. Oh!
S: You know what would be useful?
M: Oh Vlad
M: Vlad S: If I knew how to turn the things. M: Uh-huh.
S: I don't know how to use the cannons! M:I can't uh- I can't exactly help you there. I'm too busy being
#/\# AMAZING #/\#
S: oh... :(
M: Yeah, I'm sorry to tell you this- why, can't I zoom in anymore? Hey? Why can't I why can't I- zoom in? WHAT DID YOU DO!?!?
How do I- what why am I like permanently zoomed out? What the heck happened?
Don't laugh at me, ya cackling fool what the hell happened? I just I'm permanently zoomed out. What? S: I honestly don't know.
M: I have no idea what happened, but uh- I'm just gonna hope for the best. Ooh, hey.
Oh, I see intelligently placed a mammoth in my path of accenting victory.
S: And your guys are hitting me with bombs. M: Yeah, that's how it works,
they got bombs, you get hit in the face, and then -uh- I win!
Correct me if I'm wrong, but I'm pretty sure that's how it works. S: I don't think that's how it works. I dont think that is how it works, I will never admit that's how it works!
EEEEEE BOOP!!!
OoOoOoOoOo
GoOoOoO
GoOo-, uh-oh-uh-oh-uh-oh good thing I have midair control on my rOOOOOck!
S: AHHP!
M: Hey uh- Hey uh- hey, hey Patrick you uh- you heard uh- this tale,
S: Of, uh
M: You heard the tale of Vlad being uh-
flattened by a big smiling boulde- BOINK!!! Oh?
That's so anticlimactic. Why can't it be incredible like *squoosh* with blood spurting everywhere?
I have no idea but I think - I think I won I'm pretty sure.
S: Well, seeing that I'm flat down like a pancake, underneath your-
*giggling* epic smiling face
That's the last thing I see is just a tiny smiley face before I just go splat!
M: Yes, I mean, it's a little bit of solace in the end of your life, but either way,
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Thank you
Patrick also known as Shodleech, if you want to see a completely different video,
where the tables might have been a little bit turned in...
*thinking of words*
...not my favor
Go check out Patrick's channel over in the description below. It is Shodleech. When are you going to get a custom URL?
S: I thought I did have a custom URL M:Not that I saw.
S: We did that the same day we made the channel! M: Oh, that's true. That's true. We did do that, anyway
It is, like, it doesn't show it, but, it is there to do in /shodleech is there alright?
I will put that link in the description below
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know you thought its down in the comments below, and as always I'll see y-. S:I'mma stop you right there!
SHOD YOU'RE MAKING THIS HARD FOR US CAPTIONERS!!!
What happened I?
I want to know, inside the comment section, if we want a third match to decide who is the better one?
Who is the better boulder. M: Oh-ho-ho-ho, you are barking up the wrong tree. You are going to get your ass spanked all over the- the-
The summer field S: I have evidence, that that is not true.
M: Yeah, I've got evidence that it's also not true for you and true for me.
S: Oh, so, yeah
Comment if you all wanna see round three to see which is that our troll face or smiley face
M:I think smiley face obviously wins,
but thank you again everybody for watching and as always we will see you,
in the next video.
BU H-BYE *voice crack*EE
Click at the thumbnails to the left to watch a new video.
Or, click on the right to get frequent updates about the wild markimoo.
k bye <3
Why are you still here?